buenas tardes mi nombre es carolina
gonzález y en más de una ocasión me han
dicho que guarde silencio que me calle
que lo que estoy diciendo no importa y
que sólo soy un exagerada y hoy me
gustaría hablar un poco sobre la
importancia de no hacerlo
quiero que pensemos en todas aquellas
situaciones donde probablemente se
sintieron incómodos como si debieran
decir algo pero al final no lo hacen
tal vez piensen en aquellos chistes o
memes de un modo oscuro
que hasta te hacen sentir mal por
encontrar en la gracia
o tal vez sea un post de alguna red
social de alguna tía primo amigo
y habla de una manera sumamente
despectiva de otros grupos de personas
pero termina diciendo que es sólo una
opinión y que respeta
o tal vez podemos pensar en aquel 8 de
marzo cuando abrieron un debate sobre
feminismo en la clase y aquel chico dijo
algo tan profundamente machista que
nadie supo cómo responderle
o incluso en aquella fiesta cuando su
amigo se encargó de que esa chica guapa
se tomara unos cuantos tragos de más y
cuando le preguntaron al respecto dijo
que porque así no le iba a decir que no
en todas estas situaciones probablemente
se sintieron incómodos conflictos
incluso como si debieran de decir algo
pero al final no lo hacemos porque si
estamos todos tranquilos aquí para que
generar un problema no vale la pena
pero realmente no la vale
muchas veces escuchamos sobre como las
acciones son lo que demuestran las
palabras se las lleva el aire
pero debemos recordar que si bien las
acciones demuestran las palabras son las
raíces las ideas son la gasolina de
todas estas acciones
me gustaría recordar lo que dice además
bien que es el asesor especial del
secretario general de las naciones
unidas para la prevención de genocidio
el holocausto no comenzó con campos de
concentración ni cámaras de gas empezó
mucho antes con discursos de odio
y así como las palabras importan
también lo hace la falta de ellas y eso
es lo que me gustaría hablar un poco el
día de hoy la importancia de no guardar
silencio ante los actos intolerantes e
injustos
ante estos actos hay muchos y hay tres
involucrados está el ofensor la persona
que comete este acto sea un comentario
un chiste incluso
estamos nosotros mismos como
observadores y usualmente hay una
audiencia
cómo afecta a cada una de estas personas
el guardar silencio
hablemos primero nosotros mismos
pasaban un acto intolerante lo vemos
decidimos no hacer nada
naturalmente vamos a buscar excusas
vamos a buscar escucharnos a nosotros
mismos para decirnos que lo que hicimos
está bien que fue lo correcto no hablar
y dentro de esta construcción de
pidiendo esta construcción de excusas se
crean lagunas dentro de nuestro propio
sistema de valores de nuestra moral y
dentro de estas lagunas puede existir la
intolerancia y la injusticia
incluso aunque es algo en lo que no
creamos conscientemente
y cuál es el peligro de esto
el día de mañana o incluso día de hoy
podríamos ser fácilmente manipulados
para apoyar y creer en cosas que
probablemente no apoyaríamos en otro
contexto porque se nos presenta la
información de una manera que es tan
cómodo no cuestionarla ni analizarla
es mejor no decir nada y aceptarlo
y es fácil manipular la información
simplemente piensen en la cantidad de
personas que hoy en día apoyan el hecho
de que hayan niños y bebés separado de
su familia en jaulas
ahora bien hablemos del ofensor
podríamos pensar que esta es la persona
que menos le importaría que al día de
mañana ni siquiera se acordará lo que
hizo de lo que hizo que no lo importa
pero el mensaje que esa persona está
recibiendo y el que nosotros le estamos
mandando esos mensajes de aceptación es
está bien lo que hiciste
no hay problema nadie te va a decir que
no porque aunque lo personal odio este
dicho el que calla otorga y lo que le
está otorgando de validación
validaciones es intolerancia validación
a ciudad esa injusticia
y si hoy nadie le dice nada qué es lo
que los detiene de ir un poco más
adelante
por ejemplo si a mis amigos les dio risa
que el chiste que hice sobre abuso a la
mujer que es lo que me detiene de ir un
poco más adelante si al final de cuentas
que tan malo puede ser si puedo bromear
con él
por último están los espectadores la
audiencia que podemos pensar que tal vez
tengan un rol mucho más pasivo dentro de
este intercambio pero el mensaje que se
llevan ellos es de igual y de igual
importancia y es muy similar que se
lleve al ofensor se llevan un mensaje de
impunidad y de indiferencia entre la
intolerancia está bien lo que esta
persona hizo la intolerancia está bien
en el importa nadie va a decir nada
y nadie te vale nadie te lo va a
castigar a indiferencia e impunidad que
permiten que hay una repetición tanto de
los actos intolerantes como del silencio
e incluso lo podemos ver desde un
aspecto un poco más grande podemos
hablar de comunidades de sociedades
donde sabemos que existe gente
intolerante y sabemos que existe la
injusticia y nadie dice nada nadie habla
al respecto entonces podemos realmente
decir que hay un problema si nadie habla
de él
en estos casos tomar una posición de
neutralidad siempre es caer del lado de
la opresión es convertirnos en cómplices
de estos actos que supuestamente
rechazamos
en muchas clases de historia o incluso
en fotos con millones de filtros que
mandan las piedras en grupos de textos
suben las redes sociales mucha gente
habla de la importancia que tienen las
palabras y las ideas de cómo han logrado
hacer revoluciones y movilizar a miles
de personas
entonces qué pasa con estas palabras son
irrespetuosas que pasa cuando estas
palabras incitan al odio
qué pasa con estas palabras son
intolerantes e injustas
de acuerdo a la historia muy peligroso
ahora bien queda claro que el silencio
el silencio tiene un impacto muy grande
dentro de estos actos
pero el hablar resuelve todo
tal vez no
tal vez no podamos cambiarla no podemos
cambiar el punto de vista de una persona
intolerante mucho menos de toda una
sociedad
pero ese rechazo directo esa resistencia
es una de las cosas más importantes y
fundamentales en la búsqueda de una
sociedad un poco más justa una un poco
más humana donde todos tengamos ese
respeto que merecemos simplemente por el
hecho existir
dice que muchos probablemente están
pensando esto porque yo misma lago y
muchas veces que su palabra no tiene
peso que sólo son una persona dentro de
miles de millones y no los va a escuchar
no caigan en este juego si importa
porque tal vez no sean la persona que
sale en televisión y que tengan miles de
seguidores no van a ganar un premio
nobel de la paz
pero si van a generar un cambio dentro
de su mundo
y eso es lo que importa
así que eso es lo que me gustaría
invitarlos el día de hoy
a que se paren que se apropien de su voz
que no vuelvan a quedarse callados que
el silencio nunca más vuelva a ser una
opción porque su palabra importa y mucho
gracias
[Aplausos]